you've talked about being vegan and I I
don't think I heard you
explain this because it connects somehow
about how you think about life
so you talk about when your family's
good you grow that like circle of
empathy you grow the community is that
how you think about being vegan
that
just the capacity of living beings on
Earth to suffer
that you just don't want to add
suffering to them yeah I mean you said
it clear
it's like nothing
in all reality
I came to a realization that nothing
really has to die for me to live yeah
yeah no animal the plants
themselves right so this is say you know
you want a steak which is probably the
most you know you know I don't know the
most expensive piece of me but let's
just say the steak is you know top of
the line nice steak and you're eating
the steak for the protein to help build
your muscle
and I don't know if you got it from a
cow or a bull but whether it's a cow or
the bull they grow to about 1500 pounds
and if it's a ball it's all muscly
muscle
and it's only eating grass
yeah yeah there's there's yeah me it's
possible to uh both as an athlete and
just as a human being to perform well
without meeting me there's something
especially in the way we're treating
animals
to deliver that meat to the plate I
think about that a lot so I I do I'm a
robotics person AI person and I think a
lot about I don't know if you think
about this kind of stuff but building AI
systems as they become more and more
human-like
you start to ask the question of are we
okay
uh
if we give the capacity for AI systems
to suffer first to feel but then to
suffer to hate and to love to feel
emotion
how do we deal with that
it starts asking the same question as
you ask of animals
are we are we okay adding that suffering
to the world right
and I don't think we should add the
suffering because it's not necessary
like when you look if it's necessary
right because we're so you know survival
or the first law of nature is
self-preservation
if you are in a desert and there's
nothing else to eat but that lizard yeah
yeah okay you gotta do what you gotta do
lizard's gotta go yeah you gotta go you
gotta do what you got to do because at
the end of the day man it's
when they say man has dominion over
these things
his Dominion is almost like a caretaker
how the way we do our Dominion we
dominated eat it cook it yeah like who
who Who's the first guy that looked at
the lobster
he was like I'm gonna eat this thing
like it's it's supposed to it's hard to
eat it yeah you got to go through a
process to get that a crab I remember we
see crabs when we was kids and I didn't
know why I was always getting itchy
throats and all that I you know you care
you don't know just eat but at the end
of the day a crab didn't provide no more
than
a finger worth of meat making
and it's hell getting that stuff getting
it out it's like it's not worth it it's
all reality you could have gave me a
you could have gave me
a
banana
and did better for my body
and my appetite and my being fulfilled
that's full like look look at the
blessings of of of of life right this
if you take a seed
or you get an apple and you eat it
and that apple is multiple seeds in it
if you plant that seed it'll give you a
whole tree with a whole bunch of apples
with all multiple seeds but if you kill
a fish
it can't reproduced it's done yeah if
you kill a cat it's done it's nothing
there's nothing coming back but when you
deal with the plants even after you eat
the apple
and then you defecate
your defecation is what feeds the ground
the cause of Apple to grow more yeah
circle of life and especially there's a
there's a guy named David Foster Wallace
he wrote a short story called consider
the lobster if you actually think
philosophically about what
from a perspective of a lobster
that's like symbolic or something
because you basically put in a in the
water like cold water and then it heats
up slowly
until until it's no more yeah it must
have been like then they started eating
lobsters in the Inquisition yeah they
just enjoy so they they'll probably
enjoy torturing animals and they realize
they're also delicious after the torture
is finished that's probably how they
discovered it